>> Bill: PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT
NOW HOLDING A VIDEO CALL WITH
NUMEROUS GOVERNORS FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE TOLD THERE ARE GUIDELINES
BEING DRAFTED TO HELP REOPEN THE
COUNTRY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS FROM THE NORTH LAWN
FILLS US IN ON THOSE DETAILS.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING, JOHN?
>> WE ARE LEARNING THOSE
GUIDELINES HAVE BEEN DRAFTED AND
REVEALED TONIGHT AT 6:00.
RIGHT NOW, THE PRESIDENT IS
WALKING THE NATION’S 50
GOVERNORS THROUGH THEM.
THE THEME OF THESE GUIDELINES IS
OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN, SOME
SPECIFIC MEDICALLY-BASED METRICS
FOR REOPENING THE COUNTRY AND
HERE IS PART OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT TONIGHT FOR AT LEAST
30,000-FOOT LEVEL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A GOVERNOR
LED INITIATIVE, IT WILL BE DATA
DRIVEN AND LAYERED.
THIS WON’T BE A COOKIE-CUTTER
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL APPROACH, IT
WILL BE SPECIFICALLY TAILORED
NOT JUST STATE-BY-STATE BUT
COUNTY BY COUNTY.
THEY WILL CONTINUE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDERS WHILE OTHERS WILL
BE ABLE TO OPEN SOONER I’M TOLD.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS HAVE ALL
SIGNED OFF ON THE GUIDELINES,
ALL THREE OF THEM AGREEING THAT
THIS IS THE WAY FORWARD.
THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
JUST BEFORE HE GOT ON THE CALL
WITH THE GOVERNORS AS HE WAS
OUTSIDE ON THE SOUTH LAWN JUST A
LITTLE WHILE AGO.
WE MET WILL BE INFORMING THEM,
AND I THINK THEY’LL BE VERY
HAPPY WITH WHAT WE’RE DOING.
THEY WANT TO WIN THIS WAR AND
WE’RE GOING TO WIN IT VERY BIG
AND HOPEFULLY VERY SOON.
>> 30,000-FOOT LEVEL IN A
CONFERENCE CALL, THE GUIDELINES
ARE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
GOVERNORS TO DRAW THEIR OWN
PLANS AS WE SAID SOME STATES
WILL BE ABLE TO OPEN MUCH
SOONER.
OTHERS ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOT
LONGER THAT YOU CAN EXPECT
NEW YORK CITY IS GOING TO TAKE A
LOT LONGER.
THE BUCK IS GOING TO STOP WITH
THE GOVERNORS THAT THIS THING IS
GOING TO BE DATA DRIVEN, NOT
DATE DRIVEN AND IT WILL BE
ULTIMATELY UP TO THE STATES TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS APPROPRIATE
FOR THEM AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL BE FOLLOWING
ALONG ALL THE WAY.
>> Bill: VERY INTERESTING,
SAID JUST LAST HOUR THEY ARE
WORKING ON THE PLANS AS YOU ARE
REPORTING THERE.
WHAT’S THE TONE THE PRESIDENT
WILL TAKE ON THIS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WILL SAY
CLEARLY THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
THROUGH AN UP EVIL THE LIKES OF
WHICH WE HAVEN’T SEEN IN A LONG,
LONG TIME, BUT HE WILL ALSO PAY
TRIBUTE AND RECOGNIZE AND SALUTE
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE HELPED US
GET THROUGH ALL OF THIS.
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
FIRST RESPONDERS, ALL OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES, THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MANAGED TO GET
SUPPLIES TO WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE, THE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
STEPPED UP.
JUST A LITTLE WHILE AGO WHEN THE
SOUTH LAWN, THE PRESIDENT PAYING
TRIBUTE TO THE TRUCKERS OF THIS
NATION WHO HAVE KEPT THE WHEELS
ROLLING ALL THROUGH THIS CRISIS
DELIVERING MEDICAL SUPPLIES,
FOOD AND OTHER ITEMS TO WHERE
THEY NEEDED TO BE.
LISTEN TO WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
>> FOR DAYS AND SOMETIMES WEEKS
ON END, THEY LEAVE THEIR HOMES
AND DELIVER SUPPLIES THAT
AMERICAN FAMILIES NEED AND COUNT
ON DURING THIS NATIONAL CRISIS
AND AT ALL OTHER TIMES, THEY ARE
ALWAYS THERE.
THEIR ROUTES CONNECT EVERY FARM,
HOSPITAL, MANUFACTURER AND
COMMUNITY IN THE COUNTRY.
IN THE WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS,
AMERICAN TRUCKERS ARE THE FOOT
SOLDIERS WHO ARE CARRYING US TO
VICTORY.
THEY’VE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
WE HAD NO PROBLEMS, IT’S BEEN
JUST GREAT AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THIS REALLY IS A WATERSHED
MOMENT IN THIS CRISIS, THE
PRESIDENT HELPING AS OF TONIGHT
SOME STATES ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO START TO MOVE TOWARD THE END
OF THE TUNNEL AND WE CAN REALLY
BEGIN TO FINALLY TURN A CORNER
ON THIS CRISIS THAT HAS GRIPPED